I don't know what to say, it's a feeling Anu, a
super famous company This hot 500
Nothing has changed My
feet ignore the alleys and the air
fc It was around the time I stopped by
Spring and after the fight I definitely came here
Always my friends  I ate the most set meal together with the monster car.
A memorial service for the president of this drive-in pull
Hello, nice to meet you.
[Applause]
Thank you very much for today
.
When you think of meat in the 2nd term, you think of beef, but when you think of yakiniku, it's meat.
[Music
] That's why I added garlic and pepper.
Don't
get me wrong, it's burnt Don't forget to share the dugong Isuka This honey black vinegar Calpis sounds delicious Sounds
like it's too much if it's a drive-in and lead It's too much The more you
ride,
the squid  ]
That's good, all our chickens are fresh To
hear it live
[music]